pharaonen schätze und wikipedia autoren
normalerweise arbeitet jeder für sich am
computer aber in dieser exkursion lernen
sie wie man museumsschätze dokumentiert
fotos man macht halt auch und anderen
menschen zur verfügung stellen einfach
unseren fotos auch noch so einen
gewissen sinn geben indem man die
einfach in die wikipedia anbringt sie
gehören zu den freiwilligen autoren in
deutschland
alle waren zuerst einfach nur leser von
artikeln
viele von ihnen sind durch das
fotografieren zu wikipedia autoren
geworden
auch für das ägyptische museum in
leipzig aktualisieren sie den wikipedia
eintrag über nick auch nun und seine
gemahlin ein ägyptischer beamter der vor
über 4500 jahren lebte für den
hobbyfotografen ist auch die fassade des
museums einen schnappschuss wert rund
zwei millionen lexikon einträge gibt es
schon in der deutschen wikipedia und
jeden tag werden es mehr
die dichtet situation ist bin ich zur
passenden zeit zur richtigen zeit am ort
an dem ihr das foto auch noch das dann
meistens auch etwas professioneller und
dann oft abends oder am wochenende wenn
ich dann zeit dazu habe
die uhr wird das bild am computer
nachbearbeitet und dann entsprechend auf
wikipedia commons veröffentlicht
eingeladen wurden sie zu einem großen
wikipedia kongress über 6000 aktive
autoren gibt es allein in deutschland
wikipedia kann immer mehr alle medien
gehören zum online lexikon dazu über 46
millionen artikel weltweit
dazu grafiken foto und filmdateien
landkarten oder statistiken weil die
sammelleidenschaft der autoren nicht
ausreicht arbeiten sie längst mit
archiven in der ganzen welt zusammen
wikipedianer möchten das gesamte wissen
der welt sammeln in der wikipedia und in
diesen schwesterprojekten aber es gibt
ja schon ganz vielen institutionen
beispielsweise und museen
kulturinstitutionen die bereits wissen
haben die bereits wissen sammeln und das
heißt was was ist es besser als sich mit
diesen institutionen zusammen zu tun
sie erhalten professionelles training in
schreib und computer workshops oder
kamera seminar in die veranstaltung
kostet 75.000 euro und die wikimedia
deutschland der dachverein findet es
wichtig dieses geld auszugeben
viele händler ist einerseits natürlich
die wikipedia weiterhin zu verbessern
die artikel zu verbessern die qualität
weiterhin zu sichern aber auch durch
diese ganzen online-kontakte sich auch
mal live zu erleben
berlin hier befindet sich wikipedia die
deutsche zentrale von wikipedia 100
mitarbeiter leistet sich das unternehmen
ihr auftrag sie sollen die qualität des
lexikons verbessern zum beispiel regeln
aufstellen um streitfälle zu schlichten
wie beim lexikon eintrag von george hw
bush der angeblich über 40.000 mal hin
und her verändert wurde
dann gibt es auch strukturen innerhalb
der wikipedia sogenannte administratoren
die dann in der regel solche
meinungsverschiedenheiten mitregieren
das bedeutet dass wir da auch schauen wo
kommen die unterschiedliche meinung her
und falls das noch immer nicht zum
erfolg führt gibt es sogar ein
schiedsgericht innerhalb der wikipedia
und woher kommt das geld hier arbeiten
sie an der jährlichen spenden kampagne
8,6 millionen euro haben rund 400.000
leser im vergangenen jahr gespendet
allein in deutschland
für sie ist die wirtschaftliche
unabhängigkeit wichtig
die hat den anspruch neutral objektiv zu
sein
zudem ist die bewegung dahinter
gemeinnützig mit werbung mit einem ass
der profit profitorientierung wäre
wikipedia ganz anders man würde ja nicht
vertrauen
man würde den inhalt nicht vertrauen die
einen spendengeld und die anderen
spenden artikel weltweit hat wikimedia
40 landesvertretungen
auf allen kontinenten das ganze wirkt
wie eine neuartige wirtschaftsform
zwischen sharing economy und sozialismus
und hier
glauben sie an den erfolg ihres
geschäftsmodells